طائرات روسيا تسرح وتمرح في سماء
الناتو والمانيا وبريطانيا
تردان. وبعد حكم الجنائية
الدولية على بوتين تراشق
الاتهامات والتصريحات يشتعل.
انقسام قادم قد يصيب الناتو بسبب
كييف. والزلنسكي يعاقب بشار
الاسد واوكرانيا تتحدث عن سلاح
مغشوش والغرب يتبرع. بحركة ذكية
اوصلت الصين اسلحتها روسيا وجيش
بكين في محيط تايوان وعلى حدود
الهند. فهل اقتربت ساعة الصفر
دمشق تضع شروطها وانقرة ترد.
بينما يمد اردوغان يده للسيسي
قائلا هاكي يدي والمنسى الماضي.
والرجل الاصفر يقلب الاوراق في
الداخل الامريكي. وعميل للاف بي
اي يكشف دهاء صدام حسين وبعد
محاولته تقسيم فلسطين ها هو
الكيان الاسرائيلي يشرب الكأس
نفسها. روسيا تتحرش عسكريا. حرب
الطائرات يشتعل فتيلها. والمعارك
لا تتوقف فتارة بين واشنطن
وموسكو وتارة اخرى بين الروس
والناتو. نعم ها هي القوات
الجوية الالمانية تعلن انها
وبالتعاون مع بريطانيا اعترضت
اربع طائرات روسية فوق بحر
البلطيق موضحة ان طائرة يورو
فايتر حربية اعترضت طائرة
توبوليج تابعة للجيش الروسي من
طراز وطائرتي سوخوي من طراز سيو
سبعة وعشرين وطائرة انتونوف من
طراز ايه انطويلف? فهل تتوقف هذه
الحرب عند هذا الحد? ام انها
ستأخذ مآلات اخرى? وهنا تتواصل
حرب الطائرات? وبعد قرار بولندا
وسلوفاكيا مد كييف بطائرات ميغ
تسعة وعشرين السوفيتية التقارير
مبررة ذلك بان اوروبا والغرب
يحاولون التخلص من سلاحهم القديم
وذلك عبر ايصاله لاوكرانيا في
المقابل ها هي الفواتير تتقيد
بينما هم يجددون مخزونهم وانظمة
الدفاع الجوي والصواريخ
والطائرات باسلحة حديثة فيال
مكركم يا هؤلاء. اما في اوكرانيا
وللعام الثاني على التوالي. لا
تزال الترسانة العسكرية للحقبة
السوفيتية تمثل العمود الفقري
للمقاومة الاوكرانية في حربها ضد
روسيا. فدبابات ونظام الدفاع
الجوي ثلاثمائة وطائرات من تسعة
وعشرين جميعها اسلحة سوفيتية
الصنع وذات جودة عالية في ارض
المعارك. فماذا عن الدعم الغربي
اذا? لننتقل الى تبعات قرار
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية. وهنا
وجدنسكي يفرحه بحق بوتين. حيث
اعرب الرئيس الاوكراني عن
امتنانه لفريق المدعي العام
والمحكمة. واصفا هذا القرار
بالتاريخي وفق تعبيره. لينضم
الرئيس الامريكي جورج بايدن الى
فرحة زينونسكي قائلا ان مذكرة
الاعتقال الصادرة عن المحكمة
الجنائية الدولية بحق بوتين
مبررة لارتكابه وبوضوح جرائم حرب
في اوكرانيا. ليأتي الرد الروسي
ويكثر عليه فرحتهم. وعلى لسان
المندوب الروسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي الذي قال ان الدول
الغربية تتجاهل الادلة على ما
وصفها بجرائم ارتكبت كييف مؤكدا
عمل موسكو على انشاء محكمة
متجذرة في القانون الدولي
لمحاسبة الاوكرانيين والغربيين
الذين ارتكبوا جرائم في
اوكرانيا. ليقول المراقبون. هذه
الجنائية لم تحاكم بوش على
جرائمه في العراق. هل تريد الان
اطلاق النار على نفسها بمحاكمة
بوتين؟ فمن يحاكم امريكا على غزو
العراق وقتل اكثر من مليون
عراقي؟ ومن يحاكم ايضا امريكا
على حرب افغانستان؟ ومن يحاكم
فرنسا على قتلها اكثر من مليون
ونصف المليون جزائري؟ ومن يحاكم
الكيان الصهيوني على احتلال
فلسطين؟ ومن يحاكم الصين على
مسلمي الايجور؟ فلنكن عادل ومن
سيعاقب هؤلاء؟ وعلى ذكر العقوبات
هنا الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي يدخل
على الخط بفرض عقوبات شخصية على
نظيره السوري بشار الاسد ووزير
خارجيته فيصل المقداد ورئيس
الوزراء حسين عرنوس وفق وكالة
نوفوستي. ومن طواحين الحروب الى
طواحين الحبوب. ها هي الخارجية
الروسية تعلن بانه تم اخطار
الجانب الاوكراني من خلال بلا
روسيين في تمديد صفقة الحبوب
لمدة ستين يوما. لتأخذنا هنا
اصوات الرصاص. حيث افادت صحيفة
بوليتكو بان نقص ذخائر حلف
الناتو الناجم عن الازمة
الاوكرانية قد يتسبب بانقسام بين
دول الحلف هذا الصيف خلال اجتماع
قادة دول الناتو الثلاثين في
لتوانيا. لتعود صاحبة التصريحات
اللاذعة المتحدثة الروسية ماريا
زخاخ وتشير الى ان روسيا منفتحة
على اي مقترحات دبلوماسية لحل
الازمة الاوكرانية. واضافت لكننا
لن نقبل بالانذارات. اي انهم لن
يعيدوا ما اخذوه بل سيفاوضون على
ما في الايدي الاوكرانية فقط.
الصين توسع حروبها. بخطة ذكية
وحركة ملتوية اجتازت الصين
عقوبات الغرب. المسيرات الصينية
تدخل على خط القتال في اوكرانيا.
وتحت اسم مسيرات تجارية
استوردتها روسيا. وباضافة بعض
التعديلات اصبحت تلك المسيرات
عسكرية وتقاتل فوق الاراضي
الاوكرانية. لتخرج الشركة
المصنعة على استحياء وتدين
استخدام مسيراتها عسكريا او ما
تسمى بجراون علي بابا وفق شبكة
سي ان ان. فيا لدهائكم اصحاب
العيون الضيقة. مساعدة الروس لا
تنسي الصين خطتها الاساسية. حيث
سجلت وزارة الدفاع التايوانية
اقتراب خمس عشرة طائرة صينية
وثلاث سفن حربية من المجالين
الجوي والبحري لتايوان مع قيام
الجيش الصيني بتدريبات منتظمة
قرب تايوان. ملوحة بكل الخيارات
للحفاظ على السيادة الصينية. ومن
البحر تنتقل الى المرتفعات. فبين
جبال الهيمالايا وهضبة التبت وضع
قابل للاشتعال في اي لحظة. وضع
هش وخطير بين الهند والصين.
فالدولتان تحشدان قواتهما
المسلحة قرب المنطقة الحدودية
المتنازع عليها. فهل يشتعل فتيل
الحرب بين الجيران مجددا? تركيا
تمد يدها للعرب. اقترب الصلح
والناس ينتظرون السلم على
الطاولة. ليرفع رئيس النظام
السوري بشار الاسد سقف شروطه
للقاء اردوغان والرئاسة التركية
ترفضها لتقترب جهود موسكو للجمع
بينهما من الفشل. لكن تركيا لا
تتوقف على الصلح مع سوريا فقط.
فهنا وزير الخارجية التركي مولود
جاووش اوغلو يصل الى العاصمة
المصرية القاهرة في اول زيارة
لوزير خارجية تركي الى مصر منذ
احد عاما. هناك قال وزير
الخارجية المصري ان هناك ارادة
سياسية للتطبيع الكامل مع تركيا
ليرد شاويش اوغلو انهم يعملون
على لقاء اردوغان والسيسي
ويشكرون مصر على المساعدات بعد
الزلزال. عدو الامس صديق اليوم
فيال افعال السياسة. الاحداث
والتطورات. عميل للاف بي اي
يتحدث. في اول لقاء مع صدام في
غضون ثلاثين ثانية عرف شيئين عني
اخبرته ان اسمي جورج بيرو وقال
على الفور انت لبناني اخبرته ان
والدي لبنانيان ثم قال انت
مسيحي. عندها سألته اذا كانت
لديه اي مشكلة في ذلك. الا انه
لم يبدي اي اعتراض. بل قال احب
اللبنانيين. واضاف بيرو ان صدام
قال لا تثق قط بلحية طويلة كهذه.
مشيرا مؤسس تنظيم القاعدة اسامة
بن لادن وفق شبكة سي ان ان. الرد
الحاسم يتواصل من بيونج يانج
وذلك ردا على التدريبات العسكرية
الضخمة بين الولايات المتحدة
وكوريا الجنوبية. حيث اعلن
ثمانمائة الف من الشباب
المتطوعين في كوريا الشمالية
استعدادهم للانضمام لجيش كوريا
الشمالية للقتال ضد امريكا.
وماذا بعد يا ابناء كيم الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب او ما يسمى
بالرجل الاصفر يعود من جديد
معلنا بانه توصل الى معلومات من
مكتب مدعي عام مانهاتن بانهم
سيعتقلونه يوم الثلاثاء القادم.
ليدعو انصاره للاحتجاج والتظاهر
وايلون ماسك يقول ان تم اعتقال
ترامب فسيفوز بالانتخابات
الامريكية القادمة باكتساح. بعد
نحو شهر من انباء مداهمة الشرطة
مكاتب مجموعة تدعى اسرائيل وهو
تلاعب بالكلمة العبرية لاسرائيل.
نشرت قناة ايت ونيفور تقريرا عن
الحادثة انها محاولات لبناء
اسرائيل جديدة. فهل هي مؤشرات
جديدة تدل على انقسام جديد داخل
الكيان الاسرائيلي? الغرب لا
يعطون اسلحتهم كدعم لاوكرانيا
فهم في الحقيقة يستبدلون اسلحتهم
القديمة فقط. برأي اهذا هو ما
يحدث حقا?